let's talk the voice now the big finale
last night and surprise surprise another
win for who coach Blake Shelton our
Cassie delor with Blake who was in his
feelings about it all Bryce Leatherwood
congratulations you should be on stage
and make my family proud and make my
home state proud that's what it's all
about
in ninth win as a coach how will you
sell
it right like this
[Music]
that's a good one that was a good one
that was a good one yeah next season
will be Blake's 23rd and final season
coaching as he joins Kelly Clarkson and
newbies Chance the Rapper and Niall
Horan the last night marked his wife's
emotional swan song this is so insane
honestly you and Gwen's final time
together I'm getting teary-eyed just
thinking about your guys's journey
together what is going through your mind
I walked over to Gwen's chair after
after the cameras went off and and
and she's over there literally sobbing
it is crazy to think of of how you know
the show's changed my life but majorly
by meeting my wife now you're trying to
make me emotional I know what you're
trying to do
Barbara Walters moment I know what
you're doing you're not gonna make me
crafts you're not gonna make me cry
[Music]